my name is Paige Morimoto and I found
out about this contest about three hours
ago and so I'm sitting in my car dr.
pick up my kid from daycare so high
quality video coming your way I've been
a screenwriter I suppose since about two
thousand and eight that's when i first
started taking classes at ucla's
professional program so I've been
interested in screenwriting but that was
really when I first learned the
structure in the formatting and things
of that nature my current script I
started outlining when I was pregnant
and as i said i'm outside daycare and he
just had a second birthday so over two
years so that's a pretty substantial
time to be working on one script that I
wouldn't really say is finished quite
yet I came up with the idea for riding
it when I was preparing for my son's
arrival I was going on craigslist and
trying to get all the things the travel
crib and the swing and the humidifier
and all the silly stuff that you need to
apparently raise a child and not have to
turn yourself in to child services for
being a terrible human being and I had
everything I needed at a stable job and
I had the amazing husband everything
going my way and it was crazy stressful
and I couldn't get over the idea of what
would I be doing if i didn't have all of
those things lined up and the idea of
this character whose life was a mess and
she had to prepare with this ticking
clock of this person that was arriving
much to her surprise got in my head and
stuck around and stayed there why
haven't I given up on her
her her name is Missy and the reason I
haven't given up on the script is I feel
like everyone gives up miss on Missy and
I couldn't add myself to the pile it
just seemed to me especially since i
paid her up let's see what is my goal
with writing my screenplay I'd say the
goal is just highlighting all of the
effort that that goes into it and the
emotional effort and the logistics of
becoming a new mom as always this you
know shopping montage on a movie or
whatnot of just oh here we got some
stuff and now I'm prepared by painting a
room and what it isn't that easy what if
you have to make yourself a fully-formed
person while you're forming a person at
the same time inside your belly and all
the stress that can go along with with
that see what has screenwriting taught
me one lesson I would say would be how
limiting your own viewpoint can be when
you're making a character you're so
informed by your own experiences that
you can write additional characters
antagonist sort of supporting people and
in your mind they're very flushed out
and they serve purposes but you won't
necessarily see how you've made them one
dimensional or stereotypical until you
share what you've written with somebody
else who has a different perspective on
it and you think to yourself my goodness
I I would never have tried to write
somebody that shallow or
no that thin of a character and it's
almost insulting when you write a
character that isn't fully fully fleshed
out as if you didn't think they deserve
to be so finding your own limitations
when you're developing a script i think
is probably the biggest lesson the fact
that everybody has it and i think you
need to accept the fact that no matter
how open you think you are as a person
you're going to have limitations and
you're not going to see them until you
share what you've written with somebody
else who has different viewpoint than
you when do i right uh well as I think
would probably be evidenced by my
current time crunch and making this
video i right when my son's asleep or i
right on the train a lot I do most of my
outlining when I'm on the metro to work
I don't know why but I think to get more
motion sick when I'm coming from in the
afternoon that and it's hard to find a
seat to write so I tend to do it namely
on my way to work in the morning if at
all possible and with the the actual out
letting if I'm the outlining to be most
important because i have so little time
if i don't have a very clear roadmap
then i'm just done before I even start
the actual writing I do when he's asleep
and I probably should be sleeping but I
think screen writings more of a
compulsion than a career a lot of the
time what are my goals my goals would be
I would love to do it full time and I'd
love for this to be my job it isn't but
i'd love for it to be so i suppose that
would be my goal to reach the point
where it is the short story about my
screen writing career um probably the
closest thing that i have i've been a
semi-finalist and some competitions and
things like that but the thing that I
hold on to
I went out to LA a few years ago and I
met a friend's neighbor I know who has
since gone on to do great things she's a
successful producer and whatnot and she
very nicely read one of my scripts that
had done fairly okay and she gave it to
her agent and he liked it but he said he
didn't get enough traction and I know
that that's not really much of a story
career wise but just having somebody who
is successful and does this for a living
she looked at my work and she said this
is what you should be doing and you know
she wasn't my mom or a friend she was
just somebody who I didn't think I
brought her wine i think we drank her
wide oh she was just a nice person who
was nice about my work and she didn't
have to be and hearing that from sort of
a professional would probably be the
best accomplishment I've had so far so
that's pretty much